so this is mac dylan
1200 from brazil
shows up fortunately
are we gonna get a king's indian here
potentially a grindfeldt
both both openings that have been
favored by by uh
several world champions or
two of the most famous ones anyway
bobby fischer and gary kasparov
but one thing they never did is that
they played e5 before castles because
usually
you would have knight e4 here as a
little tactic winning the pawn back
because the knight e4
and bishop p5 but in this case
f7 was hanging and this meant
that my brazilian opponent
has just lost a pawn
for actually a very nice central pawn
for
very little compensation
uh so f4
fortifying the knights next i want to go
[ __ ] v3
and possibly long castles
c6 is uh a move that
um that very strong players would
usually play out automatically here by
the way
just to take away the d5 square
for for my knight
question is do i want to go knight d5
jack
think that bishop d5 ed5
might have c6 then probably don't want
to
so i'm just gonna
um just gonna develop instead
um now that he prevented long castles
i'm just going king f2
no reason to castle uh the king is very
very safe here
c6 he does a very good move again
taking control over the
d5 square this is the advantage that
black often has in the
in the king's indian is that you can
take
um you can take control of
the d5 square while the white pawn is
already on c4
and the other one on e4 so you cannot
actually control the d4 squares
square is white which means that in a
lot of in a lot of the positions where
black goes e5 and you go d5 d5 and the
pawn on e5 is not hanging
then the d4 square will potentially be
weak for for white
while the
d5 square can be covered uh with a pawn
from c6's black so that that is one of
the um
one of the advantages of that opening i
have a little tactic here
um knight with rook d8
check king e7 was obviously the
um the natural response there uh it
looks as though
my king will uh my rook will be driven
back but i had would have had rook takes
b8
and then knight c6 check uh takes v8
with um
with a win over piece now however uh
after knight c6
um this is um yeah more precise
uh i just win win at least
an exchange after knight c6 and rook a8
obviously living with me with a
completely winning position
next i probably want to go c5
to um to open up even more and uh
create at least one
pass pawn on the on the queen side
taking c3 doesn't probably the best move
but it doesn't help
that much in that regard since c5 is
still
still happening and
i'm still still getting that past pawn
i could have taken an a7 there as well
but um
c5 i think maybe even better seeing as
now after
bc5 i do get
to i do win
um uh the knight in e8 as well
and my opponent
very respectfully uh resigned which i
appreciate
um i i with when you're relatively low
rated i
i don't at all mind if you play on
either but
obviously um resigning so that we can
get to
to play even more people is also um
it's also not something something in
mind